this March Netflix is heating up its
lineup with more original movies and TV
shows than you can shake a fire stick
app whoa we're staring down the barrel
of over 50 new original releases
including new seasons of Jessica Jones
Santa Clarita diet and a series of
unfortunate events and that's just the
beginning
here's everything to look forward to on
Netflix in March 2018 starting with the
Netflix originals 21 Thunder season 1
Netflix is kicking off the month with 21
Thunder a dramatic sports series that
centered on a fictional soccer team
called the Montreal Thunder from the
trailer it looks like a Friday Night
Lights for the soccer crowd following
the players and coaches through the
drama of their personal lives both on
and off the field cue up season 1 on
March 1st Flint town the town of Flint
Michigan made headlines in 2014 when
officials discovered that over 100,000
people have been exposed to contaminated
water now Netflix is centering a new
documentary series on the controversial
Berg from a different angle
Flint town follows the town's law
enforcement as they deal with crime
violence an outrage in the wake of the
water crisis tune in for every
nail-biting moment on March 2nd girls
incarcerated season 1 this new
documentary series goes behind bars in
juvenile women's prisons to follow the
day-to-day lives of their young inmates
I've been locked up in and out for like
4 years 6 month free year in 3 days
season 1 of girls incarcerated arrives
on March 2nd so tune in for all the
drama the justice system has to offer
ravenous also known by its original
title of lays up am a ravenous is a
Canadian drama about a small group of
survivors in rural Quebec struggling to
survive against a zombie horde ravenous
debuted at the 2017 Toronto
International Film Festival to generous
reviews and walked away with the Award
for Best Canadian film there's not much
more hype we can give it so check it out
when it hits Netflix on the second of
the month
the world's most extraordinary homes
season 1 think you've got a crazy home
just because you spent your life savings
on lawn flamingos there's something you
don't see every day trying to think of
the most part most think something I
loved from my childhood well think again
this Netflix rebranding of the BBC 2
show takes
stunning look at some of the most
radical residences on the planet form
architectural wonders nestled deep in
the woods too extravagant island
retreats check out season 1 on March 5th
Jessica Jones season 2 as one of the
original Marvel shows on Netflix fans
have been waiting for a second season of
Jessica Jones since 2015 only to feel
their souls constrict a little more
every year it didn't happen well the
long bitter wait is over tune in for
more episodes of everyone's favorite
alcoholic super heroine on March 8 to
remember forget giving a better tip bad
guys vile city season 1 this South
Korean crime thriller is a direct
spin-off of the 2014 award winning
series bad guys which saw three
criminals released from prison to help
track down even worse criminals bad guys
vile City follows the same premise with
a new cast and looks just as riveting as
the original series check it out on
March 8 ladies first
if you follow Olympic archery you'll
probably recognize the name Deepika
Kumari one of the top female archers in
the world ladies first is a new
documentary that exposes Kumari's roots
to the streets of India and traces her
hard-fought journey from poverty to one
of the world's most elite athletes tune
in for what's bound to be an emotional
journey on March 8 collateral for
high-octane murder mystery thrills look
no further than collateral a limited
series about an assassination on the
streets of London and a police detective
who's certain there's more to the story
than meets the eye
starring mud bounds Carey Mulligan
collateral looks like a sleek thrilling
mystery that'll keep you hooked until
the last episode find out when it
premieres on March 9 love season 3 in
this comedy series created by Judd
Apatow Paul rust and Gillian Jacobs star
as Gus and Mickey two 20-somethings
caught up in an erotic whirlwind of
modern romance you can experience all
the ups and downs when season 3 of love
drops on March 9th
Heiko incarnation season 1 Netflix is
rolling out a good half dozen new anime
series in March and one of the most
exciting looks to be ICO incarnation
this futuristic sci-fi story starts with
an experiment gone wrong that creates an
losing AI monstrosity called
matter that's threatening to destroy the
city and maybe the world now it's up to
a bionic 15 year old girl named Aiko to
save everyone strap on your roller
skates and mark your calendars for March
9th
my next guest needs no introduction with
David Letterman Malala yousufzai in the
previous two installments of David
Letterman's well-received hour-long talk
show the late-night maven sat down with
Barack Obama and George Clooney this
month Letterman is hosting a one-on-one
with Malala yousufzai the youngest
person ever to be awarded the Nobel
Peace Prize take a look when the newest
episode lands on March 9th nailed it
season 1 Netflix calls this cooking
competition show part reality contest
part hot mess which doesn't sound like
your average cooking show can't forget
the vodka the show handpicks a group of
terrible bakers and then hits them
against each other in a culinary
cook-off for a $10,000 grand prize
tune in for all the mayhem on March 9th
B outsider starring Jared Leto as a
soldier forced to begin working for the
Yakuza in exchange for his freedom the
outsider definitely looks like an epic
story with some seriously brutal action
sequences look for it on March 9 terrace
house opening new doors part 1 the
premise of this japanese-language
reality series is instantly familiar a
group of young people live in a house
filled with cameras but rather than the
fights in the drama of similar shows
like the real world or Big Brother there
isn't a lot that happens in terrace
house it's just six people being pretty
nice to each other for 30 minutes at a
time you can watch a group of people
sitting around watching TV and awkwardly
making eye contact
where will Terrace house opening new
doors take us the suspense is gently
apologetically killing us but we'll all
just have to wait until March 13th to
find out tabula rasa season 1 this
series centers on a woman with total
amnesia who finds out she's the prime
suspect in a murder investigation to
convince the police that she had nothing
to do with the murder she has to dig
into her subconscious to prove that
she's innocent it looks like a trippy
psychological ride so don't miss it when
season 1 premieres on March 15th take
your pills can one drug define a
generation that's the
question asked by take your pills
directed by Alison Clayman this
documentary looks at the excessive use
of stimulants like ritalin and adderall
in schools and workplaces cue it up on
March 16th wild wild country in 1981 an
Indian guru began building a city in
Oregon planning to turn the fringe
community into a desert utopia the group
was later found to be behind the largest
bioterrorist attack in US history and a
plot to assassinate a government
official wild wild country is an
unforgettable journey through the
group's formation and their later
downfall look for it on Netflix on March
16 on my block season 1 in urban LA for
teenagers struggle to fit in at their
new high school while dealing with life
in the inner city that's the premise for
on my block a new comedy from the
creator of MTV's awkward the first
season arrives on March 16th Aida season
1 there's a lot going on in the trailers
for Aida an Argentinian series focused
on the dark side of the Buenos Aires
fashion industry but the main takeaway
is that this is shaping up to be a
pretty brutal show in a world of greed
and betrayal who can you really trust
find out on March 16 the legacy of a
white-tailed deer hunter plot details
about the legacy of a white-tailed deer
hunter have been few and far between but
all we need to know is that it stars
Danny McBride and Josh Brolin and it was
produced by the folks behind eastbound
and down should be an interesting ride
the movie is scheduled to premiere at
the 2018 South by Southwest Film
Festival before its March 16th launch on
Netflix
Leila M politically charged and
culturally relevant Leila M is a story
about an 18 year old Muslim girl living
in Amsterdam who's dealt with
discrimination or whole life but when
she marries a man with ties to a
middle-eastern Islamic self her whole
world changes tune in for the riveting
journey on March 23rd Requiem season 1
originally aired on bbc1 Requiem is a
fantasy thriller about a young woman who
heads out to a small village in the
country to find answers about her past
there she discovers a supernatural force
that may threaten everything she's ever
known take a look when season one hits
Netflix on March 23rd Roxanne Roxanne
written and directed by Michael Larnell
this Netflix original movie tells the
true story of Roxanne Shantae a female
rapper who became a legend of hip hop in
the mid 80s Roxanne Roxanne follows the
teenage MC through her early years and
chronicles her rise to fame get with the
beat on March 23rd game over man from
the team behind workaholics comes one of
the most anticipated Netflix films of
early 2018 game over man
the workaholics crew star as three
slacker waiters who have to rise to the
challenge when the hotel where they work
is taken over by terrorists tune in for
the laughs on March 23rd Santa Clarita
dyin season 2 this zombie comedy
starring Drew Barrymore and Timothy
olifants received rave reviews over the
course of its first season leaving fans
clamoring for a second almost from the
beginning it may have taken a year but
their wishes have finally been answered
look for it on March 23rd the mechanism
season 1 loosely based on a real-life
corporate scandal the mechanism is a
scripted drama series that looks into
corruption and greed with narcos
executive producer jose padilla as
showrunner you know it's going to be a
crazy ride take a look on March 23rd
Lemony Snicket's A Series of Unfortunate
Events Season 2 winding down the month
Netflix is rolling out the second season
of a series of unfortunate events with
the events of books 5 through 9 as the
main focus of the upcoming season if you
can't get enough of Count Olaf and the
Baudelaire orphans mark your calendar
premiering March 30th Cheers
rapture Netflix is doubling down on
their hip-hop history with rapture an
eight-part documentary series that takes
a magnifying glass to the biggest rap
stars on the planet if you've ever
wondered what goes on in the personal
lives of celebs like 2 Chainz gez and a
boogie with the hoodie you'll finally
get your chance to find out on March
30th first match continuing their theme
of female empowerment in honor of
International Women's Day Netflix is
releasing this hard-hitting drama about
a teenage girl who joins an all-boys
wrestling team the movie is based on a
short film of the same name that won
some awards in 2000 look for it on March
30th
happy Anniversary in this indie comedy a
young couple take a hard look at their
marriage and tried to decide whether
they want to get a divorce on their
three-year anniversary happy Anniversary
happy Anniversary stars Ben Schwartz and
Noel Wells and premieres on March 30 the
Titan Netflix hasn't promoted this
upcoming sci-fi thriller but one of the
film's writers confirmed on Twitter that
the Titan will indeed be released as a
Netflix original Sam Worthington stars
as a soldier who gets genetically
altered to survive on Saturn's moon
Titan mark your calendar the Titan shows
up on March 30th trailer park boys
season 12 canada's trailer park heroes
are back for yet another season of their
award-winning comedy series season 12
we'll see Julian Ricky and bubbles doing
more things than ever
two things that dogs don't mix with
Katie's and baubles check it out on
March 30th Trump an American dream
season 1 this month
Netflix is pointing their political
spotlight on the White House with Trump
and American dream a Netflix rebranding
of the UK produced documentary about
Donald Trump the series will dig through
over 5 decades of the current POTUS past
season 1 drops on March 30th original
stand-up comedy keep your eyes peeled
for a host of brand new stand-up comedy
specials this March with a heavy focus
on international acts look for a new
special by Adele Karim on March first
followed by milena Pinchot and Natalya
Val de Veneto on the second as the month
rolls on Netflix will drop dead
Millay American dream on the sixth ricky
gervais see on the 13th and season two
of the stand-ups on March 20th if you're
looking for laughs you're definitely in
the right place that covers all the
Netflix originals now let's look at all
the other movies and TV shows coming to
Netflix in March 2018
new movies Netflix is only bringing a
handful of new action movies this month
for sword and sandals epics we've got
300 arriving on the 1st and 2017 Troy
the Odyssey coming on the 12th on the
sci-fi spectrum look for 23:07 winter's
dream on the 1st along with battle drone
and I am Number Four in the mood for
lighter fare Netflix is adding a great
selection of comedies in March the first
of the month we'll see ghostbusters 1 &
2 beer fest and the bucket list hitting
the streaming service also keep an eye
out for jackass number two and jackass
3.5 on the 1st and 15th respectively
there won't be a whole lot of change on
the documentary front this month but the
few films that are arriving will
definitely be worth watching look for
expedition China on the 4th Conor
McGregor notorious on the 21st and the
red trees on the 24th and if that's not
enough drama Martin Scorsese's casino is
joining the Netflix ranks on the 1st
along with Gridiron Gang moon
Revolutionary Road and up in the air go
ahead and take our money now to take my
two new family arrivals on the first of
the month include the animated adventure
comedy Alpha and Omega and Stuart Little
3 call of the wild on the 6th relive the
classics with 1974's Benji and the 1977
sequel for the love of Benji just in
time for Netflix's original Benji reboot
on March 16 finally
Netflix's new thriller lineup is heating
up along with the weather all 3 Cruel
Intentions films arrive on the first
side by side with hostage the descent
and the gift finally let me in is
showing up to creeped out audiences at
the end of the month
look for that on the 31st new television
March won't herald the arrival of much
new television with only 5 non Netflix
shows landing throughout the month on
March 1st look for the 18th season of
Law & Order SVU followed by the second
season of the Hollywood
Masters on March 15 finally the month
ends with the 2018 season of man on a
mission on March 27th and the kid Series
miraculous tales of ladybug and cat noir
on the 30th thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]